hey everyone it's Mike from waterfalls
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
I want to be talking about Market
exhaustion you know yesterday I talked
about Market exhaustion using the volume
is traded in the bar
um at the sort of extremes you know
turning points in the market
but I did get a question from a user
asking why did not show exhaustion with
the help of the order flows ratios and
actually that's what today's topic is
about because there's more than one way
to skin the cat you know there's more
than one way to determine exhaustion
taking place in the market so before I
jump in you know if you enjoy learning
from my videos be sure to hit the
Subscribe button and click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new upload and if you find today's video
helpful hit the like button for me and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway or you know leave a comment
asking you know what you'd like to see
in another video you know I love hearing
your feedback and your sport really does
go a long way in helping me create more
videos just like this
so again if you're getting value for my
channel want to see more be sure to hit
that subscribe button and let's grow
together
so let's go ahead and get started on
today's topic alright so let's get into
it so remember yesterday right I did a
video talking about
um
identifying
Market exhaustion through the exhaustion
print in the order flows Trader okay so
in the settings right you can see it in
here exhaustion prints right in there I
talked about that that's one way to
determine the exhaustion in the market
okay and you know as a result of me
posting that video
um
here Amy trying to pw3jp
left of comment saying you know is there
any reason you did not show exhaustion
with the help of flow ratios okay so you
know one of the things that I've been
known for
in order flow is developing these
numbers you see above and below the bar
now that's different that's not Delta or
anything like that what that is it's
taking
um the volumes that's trading at the top
of red candles
and finding out what the ratio is of the
order flow okay
or the bottom of green candles that's
why you see some red numbers and some
blue numbers if it's just the normal
order flow going through it's just going
to be a black number like 1.82 2.23 0.97
okay now there's two types of order flow
ratios there's a ratio bonds High
there's a ratio bounds low okay it's
funny because I've seen people copy
this whole concept of these ratios you
know since I first released the order
flows Trader in 2015 you know it was
copied immediately by some other
software companies and they you know
were marketing as laughing because it's
you know they Market it as the order
flow algo right like it was some super
duper secret sauce and it's not I mean
you could figure it out yourself just by
looking at what the volumes are trading
at the tops of the red candles the
volumes training at the bottoms of green
up candles and really what you're
looking at
is
the ratio okay how the top of a red
candle offer side is forming or the
bottom of a green up candle how that is
forming okay now
just really quick there are two types of
ratios okay now I used to do these
things in my head you know before
I sat down with the programmer and said
hey you know what this is how I look at
order flow right I used to just
calculate that because I could look at
the volume and sort of do the math in my
head sometimes I'd have to use a
calculator but generally speaking it's
pretty easy so again there's two types
ratio bounds High which indicates price
exhaustion and it's a number 30 and
above okay there's ratio bonds low which
indicates price defense that's 0.69
and below it would go from 0.69 to zero
it can't go below zero okay you can't
have as a negative number for a ratio
and it's funny because I see people
copying my
this concept and literally using the
exact same levels and it's funny because
you know I've adjusted these over the
years I used to use 25 for Price
exhaustion I used to use one for price
of Defense I've just sort of honed it in
based on my own trading and the markets
that I trade because you know honestly
in other markets you could probably
still use 25 and one but um let's take a
look here really quick so this is uh 10
years right it's a four range chart and
you can see at this high of the day
you've got a
red number 66.96 all I'm really
concerned about is is it above 30 if
it's above 30 for a ratio bounds
High okay 30 and above I don't care what
the ratio is all I care about is it's
colored red indicates to me that it is
price exhaustion okay so 30 and above
it's price exhaustion on a red candle
above
30 and above on a green candle is price
exhaustion so you're going to see here
okay
all right we got this high up here right
and this goes back to the whole concept
of you know other software copying my
ideas you know I don't mind them copying
my ideas again you know order flow is
available to everybody right and we
could all sort of figure it out
ourselves but
when I see software copying it and they
don't understand how to use it that's
what bothers me okay honestly is because
you know they they put it in their
software like oh yeah we have that in
there by our software but they don't
understand the logic behind it and how
to apply it to trading and it's sort of
you know leaves a gap so to speak in the
analysis so you know they'll take it and
say well every time you got a you know a
blue number below the bar it's bullish
or a red number or above
a bar is bearish well that's not really
the case right because if it's Market
exhaustion
where are you looking for the market for
exhaustion to come in at
well
you're looking at exhaustion coming in
at a swing high or a swing low
right so here we are rallying up to a
swing high right I have a ratio balance
low 66. now if you're looking at the
volumes you know you see 49 2000 3800
okay I'm sorry 3200 so 49 3200 2200 it
just looks like normal order flow but
then
by using your flows ratio right it's
doing the calculation it's telling you
no there's actually price exhaustion
taking place up here now you're at the
high of the day and you have price
exhaustion
what do you think the Market's going to
do you're going to look for the market
to potentially sell off now people are
going to say well you have bullish
ratio here here and here you know
Market's not going up well
is this move is you know you got to be
asking is this where I'm going to be
looking for exhaustion no right if
you're looking for bullish exhaustion
right where are you going to be looking
for it well you should be looking for
Bullock's exhaustion near the low
because it's telling you that the move
down is getting exhausted all right it's
like you know here this was at 6 42 last
night this was at nine o'clock 9 p.m
last night
you know this one started to go up
and came right back down here we hit
that low and rallied up to the high so
if you're looking at these ratios you
got to put it in context of the market
right
if you're looking for bullish ratios you
want to find them
at
Lowe's swing lows all right if you're
looking at bearish ratios you want to
see them at highs or you know swing
highs okay now there's a setup that I
like to use
this is sort of one of my bread and
butter setups if you would you know you
always hear people say oh you know
I I had a bad day I should just only
take my a plus setups
why aren't you just taking your a plus
setups to begin with you know I was like
I don't get it you know these
professional
um what do you call it professional
funding program traders that that blow
up the accounts oh I should I should
have only taken my a plus settings my a
plus setup say well you should only be
taking your a plus setups I mean I don't
know why you all of a sudden think
you're some Master Trader but what my
what this setup entails okay just give
me a second here
um let's make this a little bit bigger
so I can expand it is it's what I call a
ratio and Divergence okay and I've been
talking about this for years
and you know people that
are you know my software users some of
them literally bought the software just
to trade this right I talk about this
almost every week in my trading
um trainings
is a Divergence right a new Oracle high
with the bearish ratio right here okay
now did the market sell off immediately
no it's sort of working its way down you
know a little bit slower you know it's
coming down rallies back up
coming down I was starting to come down
this is uh Friday afternoon already
bullish ratio bullish ratio Divergence
Divergence right did it go up you know
it went up a little bit but this is the
nice move from the low all the way up to
new highs and you know you see here
bullish ratio bullish ratio bullish
ratio bullish ratio the market didn't
put it in a rally right away I mean it's
just hanging going sideways like but you
don't have the Divergence
okay so again no this is all price
exhaustion here now another question
people ask me is does it matter
like here you've got a
ratio of 406.
and here's 32 is the 406 stronger than
the 32 no it's treated the same as long
as it's blue I don't care if it's 4 600.
versus 32. all I'm really cared about
because it's a racial remember it's just
looking at the ratio of the volume
that's taking place at the different
levels all I'm really concerned with is
is it
um
you know over my threshold of 30.
so you can see you know there was no
Divergence coming in on any of these
right because it's all it's still
negative Delta down here
okay
finally it did rally up but I just find
those to be the strongest uh potential
trading opportunities right where you
have the Divergence that's this gold
color here with the ratio and again
there's going to be times like this
where you know you get your Divergence
and ratio and I mean it sort of goes up
a little bit but it's not the big move
but then it comes down makes that new
load then makes the the move that you're
expecting
Okay so
when you're in a trade as okay another
way I like to use ratios okay is
if I'm in a trade the market is just
sort of like hanging around going
sideways then it gives me a this is what
I'll talk about this in a separate video
or racial bounds low which indicates
price defense right point two fours it's
0.69 to zero so again if it's a bullish
ratio
and
if it's in the move that I'm in you know
to me that's a sign of you know
reassurance it's not necessarily
assigned to look to get in right because
there should already be in off the ratio
and Divergence but then I see you know
something to confirm with me that hey
you know what yeah this move is now
we're running you know we're pulling
back and we're running into price
support that you should be looking for
the market to uh keep going higher
so let's take a look at e-minis today
okay so this is the 10 years right and
you know not everyone trades 10 years
and everyone wants to a lot of Traders
like to watch the e-minis right because
a lot of movement right a lot of
opportunity and the same thing right I'm
looking at any time we hit a low I'm
looking for the bullish ratio and the
Divergence okay right here
you got the positive Delta of 19. I mean
there's some other bullish things in the
order flow as well here right you see
the nice Delta increase 19 for 84 964 in
here but just this alone the ratio the
bullish ratio and the Divergence
right the gold and the blue to me that's
an automatic trade as long as the next
bar starts trading higher which it does
you see it rallies up from you know what
is that 65 65 and a quarter all the way
up into the 70s does pull back to sort
of your entry price goes back up pulls
back down to literally the the previous
low right now you have a Divergence you
don't have a ratio
but again if you're trading this ratio
and Divergence where's your stop well
your stop is right below the where the
ratio is coming in so you know a tick or
two lower
because if the market comes down here
and takes out this ratio and this
Divergence
there's no need to be long right so
again you know what's your what's your
risk right you're getting long probably
from 65 65 and a quarter 65 and a half
your stops down here at 62 and a half
three points okay you got I mean it made
that move five points did pull back here
tested it 62 and three quarters you know
still holding you know gets within a
tick of your stop then boom and then it
makes this nice gigantic uh move up that
we're seeing right now right it's you
know I'm not you know again from if
you're long from 65 and a half you know
geez where are we trading now Trading
85.
okay
and you know just let's see if there's
any more ratio and Divergence you know
because you see here right as the move
is going down bearish ratio Bears ratio
Bears ratio Bears ratio bearish ratio
bearish ratio you don't see any bullish
ratios you see one here
but when you're in a trade and you start
seeing you know when you're positioned
directionally you start seeing those
ratios going in your direction that's
nice to see and people say well you got
one here you got bullish one here a
bullish one here yeah but overall it's
mostly negative
um
okay and again you know as I say it's
not just about trading every single
ratio right you want to put it in
context of the market now here you got a
high but there's no ratio because it's a
green candle so it's not looking for you
know exhaustion or defense at the bottom
of
or at the top of a green candlest
looking for it at the bottom of the
green candle
okay right here 43 right 4 172 81 you
know 150. so again if you're using
exhaustion prints
you know and you have it set at one two
three you're not going to notice this
right the ratio is helping you pick it
up I mean now if you set your exhaustion
print at nine yeah the four would also
show so not only when you have a bearish
ratio but you'd have the Divergence got
negative Delta minus 629 as well but
this is the ratio 43 and the Divergence
the negative Delta at the High
and again where's your stop well your
stop is just behind this High 96 and a
quarter 96 and a half were you looking
to get short you know 91 and a half
somewhere in here right below the low of
this bar you want to make sure the
market is going in your direction call
it 91 and a half or if it does pull back
two points
for selling off down to 87 and a half
and then going sideways here it does
make a new high but again you know
it can be a powerful move
right sometimes you can see you go
literally from the low to the high but
you got to determine how you're trading
all right if you're trading a one minute
chart
I don't think it's fair to have a two
hour time frame of your trade
okay if you're trading a short you know
if you're a longer term Trader you know
five minute 15 minute chart or a swing
Trader yeah you can hold positions for
hours but if you're on a short time
frame of you know a minute 30 seconds
you know
ideally you know you want to keep it
within 15 20 minutes maybe 30 minutes
you're not looking to get short here at
10 o'clock and hold it all day you know
until 11 12 1 2 o'clock no
um
you want to take what the Market's going
to give you because you're a short-term
intraday Trader all right
so I hope that uh that's gonna wrap up
this video
um you know I hope you find these tips
helpful for your understanding of order
flow especially with the ratios this was
a ratio balance High
which indicates price exhaustion
lesson
so let me know what you would like to
discuss next by leaving a comment below
and again you know if you enjoy my
videos make sure you subscribe to the
channel and hit the like button and to
hit the notification button as well so
you don't miss any new upcoming videos
so thanks so much for watching and I'll
catch you guys on the next video bye bye